just a warning though that her report
contains some flash photography
it's been a tour where more than usual
the couple have been under pressure to
address certain issues that are big
talking points across the caribbean
[Music]
we didn't expect this from prince
william's only speech in the bahamas a
clear statement about how he and the
royal family feel about other realms
cutting ties
i want to say this we support with pride
and respect your decisions about your
future
relationships evolve
friendship endures
it hadn't been the easiest of days
the weather not playing ball
but there was no way they could miss a
famous junkanoo parade wherever they are
and whatever the weather is often been
said that the royals are in the
happiness business and the issues going
on during this tour though could not be
bigger which means the stakes are really
high when it comes to potentially
putting a foot roll
at the end of the same street we found a
museum named after pompey a slave who
led a rebellion in 1830
part of our shared history that some
believe they should be compensated for
we think of reparations as a way of
gaining justice and repairing the damage
that was
endured through the transatlantic slave
trade and as well as the
underdevelopment that was left not only
in the bahamas but really in the
caribbean as a region
over the road from the museum kent and
kevin were more indifferent will be not
independent we now be given freedom
okay so slavery to me has been like it's
been abolished so why go back
some have felt that elements of this
tour have felt a bit colonial or
outdated from the couple there have been
efforts to balance that like a school
visit focusing on the impact of covid
and throwing themselves into whatever's
been asked of them even in the pouring
rain they showed themselves to be good
sports
a competitive pair but realizing they
both have an important role to play when
it comes to making this tour a success
or not
[Music]
rihanna mills sky news in nassau bahamas